[Music]
welcome
to the mit center for art science and
technology's 2021 symposium
unfolding intelligence the art and
science of contemporary computation
cast was established in 2012 with the
goal of building
and building on connections between the
worlds of art science and technology
this is the third in a series of
symposia the cast has convened since
then and as with its predecessors
we bring together artists scientists
engineers and humanists
from within mit and from the world at
large to discuss areas of rapidly
evolving research and urgent social
relevance
and defined in that dialogue stimulation
confirmation
provocation intersection and we hope
common purpose at mit
cast partners with departments labs and
centers to integrate the arts across the
curriculum
to enrich and encourage artistic
collaboration and to provide support to
faculty and members of the mit community
as they pursue their own artistic
practice and or research
in addition to symposia like this cass
facilitates the sharing of this creative
work beyond the institute
by producing concerts exhibitions and
publications
and making them available to the public
so thank you for being with us today we
hope you will join us throughout the
week at virtual events addressing the
aesthetic
technical and critical issues pertaining
to artificial intelligence
and computational media we also look
forward to seeing you
on friday april 9th as the symposium
culminates
with a live interactive event to which
all attendees are invited
and which you can join presenters and
artists in breakout rooms
to explore hidden threads between all
that has been discussed
this week
[Music]
welcome to the unfolding models panel of
the unfolding intelligence symposium
convened by the mit center for art
science and technology
i'm professor of anthropology stephen
helmerich and i'm thrilled to introduce
to you three exceptional speakers for
this session
yale university physicist and professor
of astronomy
priyamvada natarajan yale university
professor in ecology and evolutionary
biology
c brandon ogbunu and glitch artist and
resolution theorist rosa menkman
in this session we examine how tools and
computation
shape the models that scientists and
artists make of the universe the world
and of models themselves dr nadarajan
a leading investigator into the
character of dark matter in the cosmos
will show us how computer simulations of
intergalactic clustering
may disclose dynamics otherwise
impossible to see
dr ubunu working at the intersection of
evolutionary biology
and epidemiology we'll discuss how
mathematical models of such phenomena
as the covid19 pandemic may be leveraged
to help us decode the causes
and consequences of disease across
scales
from the biophysics of proteins involved
in drug resistance
to the effects of structural racism on
health chances
and outcomes rosa menkman
a visionary in the field of glitch art
asks how the materiality
structure and resolution of data formats
contour scientists and wider public's
sense of what computer simulation can
show
and mean questions that she asks
by zeroing in on and curating moments of
noise
and stutter within the circuits of both
analog
and digital representation as you watch
the presentations of these extraordinary
thinkers i invite you to think across
them
about how computer models can act as
theory
animated in cosmology biology
aesthetics with consequences that may be
all at once
epistemological political and world
bending
think of the models that unfold through
computation as
abstractions made code made new tools
for representing
and intervening i'll close and open
with an acknowledgement that mit sits on
the traditional
unseated territory of the people of the
wampanoag nation
traditional stewards of this land who
have endured a painful history of
genocide
and forced occupation and who along with
other indigenous peoples as well as
those
who have suffered under conditions of
unfree labor
are still here working to survive and
thrive
now offering an acknowledgement like
this through the many reticulated loops
of data clouds and
cables it requires brings our bits to
you through a tangle
a glitch work even of further land
air and sea sovereignties something that
requires us to think afresh
about what we model when we model with
computers
about how computation
computation-enabling
acknowledgement-based protocols
like those of the transmission control
protocol or tcp
might be remodeled to serve better and
more just
unfoldings of our knowledge and politics
please join me then
in thinking through questions of what
kinds of universes
and worlds might yet be made in silico
and beyond
hi i'm priya natarajan an astrophysicist
and cosmologist at yale where i'm also
the director of the frankie program in
science and the humanities
a lot of my work involves the analysis
and running of cosmological
simulations and i am delighted
to be invited to speak at this
very unique and exciting conference on
the art and science of contemporary
computation
so i would like to thank the organizers
for this opportunity
and i'm going to argue and hopefully
persuade you at the end of my talk
that simulations and cosmology play a
very very special role
they play a mediatory role between
theory and observations
astronomy as you know is an inherently
observational science and it is the
power of the image
the visual that has a key role in
driving discovery
explanation and creation of new
knowledge that is quite apart from other
fields
in physics and cosmology in particular
cosmological simulations are also
distinctly apart from their counterparts
in other subfields in physics and other
sciences where computation has come to
play a significant role
because they will as i show uh
demonstrate in
uh the talk they actually play a
generative role
increasingly especially with the
combined use of machine learning
techniques
so the old critiques of the role of
simulations posit
that computer simulations do not really
yield any new knowledge or understanding
about the world because we
put into them what is already part of
some pre-existing scientific model
since we create the model we must know
it very well and at best the computer
simulation
might make the consequences of the model
visible that is it shows us the
solutions within the space of
possible solutions for the model and
allows us to see
how the simulation given some boundary
and initial conditions
will play out for us full non-linear
exposition of the underlying model
moreover there are no guarantees that
the computer simulation
just as any other physical mechanism
would be
error free indeed computer simulations
have limits in terms of their resolution
and their reliability but our input
assumptions do ratchet into an impact
our conclusions
as one of the case studies that i will
uh talk about today
uh will show however as i hope to show
you today there are
enormous epistemic gains due to this
unique mediatory role
that cosmological simulations play
simulations are not just a direct
implementation of a scientific model on
a machine they vastly enhance a creative
capacity expand
what can and is explained and open up
new windows
and realms and facets of models that are
not amenable to pencil and paper
calculations
just as physical theories are certified
by experience and expertise at least
this is
what we believed so far while analyzing
other subfields in physics simulations
play a very important epistemic role in
cosmology due to some of the inherent
paradoxes in cosmology the simulations
offer a very novel and powerful way of
reasoning
and exploring properties of theories and
models
of a single universe that we have one
that we are sitting in the middle of
as we observe and cannot perform
controlled experiments i think the key
thing that distinguishes cosmological
simulations
is the fact that in cosmology we cannot
perform
controlled laboratory experiments and
that simulations
are the proxy that permit us to do that
philosophers of science like peter
gallison have argued in his wonderful
book image and logic
he's examined the practice of science in
particle physics has interrogated the
diversity of scientific
subcultures that participate and
collaborate in the production
of data and he proposes this idea of a
trading zone
trading between theory and experiment an
uneasy
yet immensely productive exchange in
relationship
um and relationship between these
communities that ultimately
is what he argues brings strength and
stability to the created knowledge
to understand the role of simulations in
cosmology i am going to argue that we
need to go beyond the idea of a trading
zone
and in fact we need to see them
simulations
as a new kind of language as an
interglot this is borrowing a term from
linguistics
where the concept of a universal glot we
have this concept where it's a new
language that comprises
words and concepts borrowed from
multiple
other languages that aims to be
intelligible to all
so in linguistics an example of this
would be esperanto
so i am going to argue that cosmological
simulations
are actually an interglot they shape
permit reconceptualization redefining
the landscape of discoveries in
cosmology
so observations theory and simulations
together play
a very cohesive dynamical collaborative
role
in
creating new knowledge and simulators
are increasing a highly professionalized
respected cadre within cosmology
and in our data-driven computational
advanced driven
science and technology research terrain
simulations have started to play a much
more significant role
in the production of new knowledge
so here's the outline of my talk today
where i'm going to talk about
what is special about cosmology and
numerical simulations of the universe
what specific purpose they serve these
simulations and how the simulations are
different from laboratory
and in particular i will focus on two
case studies
that focus on the black hole growth
problem
which is trying to understand how
supermassive black holes grow
in the context of structure formation in
the universe
the formation the fueling and feedback
of
black holes and in particular
i will focus on some correlations
observed correlations
whose deeper underlying causation we are
yet to
really comprehend first i want to
discuss
the paradox of cosmology so the paradox
of cosmology is that there's some
fundamental insurmountable epistemic
limits that
is the fact that the inability to
perform controlled experiments on the
universe so we have one universe
and we have a peculiar vantage point
that we are inside this universe we are
making observations and we are trying to
construct an understanding of this
universe
and additionally from what we know so
far the dominant constituents of this
universe are invisible and their
presence is inferred only indirectly
there are some surmountable limits and
they of course have to do with the
limits
of models and tools and ways of knowing
and structure formation in the universe
is modulated by unseen entities so
the primary constituents of the universe
are dark
dark matter and dark energy so dark
matter
um influences the universe
by gravity and it offers the scaffolding
within which all the other assembly of
structure happens in the universe
dark energy we believe drives the
accelerating expansion of the universe
and black holes that we now know seem to
play a much more significant role once
believed to be quite marginal they play
a very significant role in modulating
the formation
of galaxies simulations
as i mentioned act as very important
mediators so they serve as epistemic
arbitrators
and they serve as this interglot
this sort of language this new language
that has common elements with both
observations and theories and models and
permits
communication seamless communication
feedback from these two realms
and i will show you with these two case
studies that simulations serve as
serve to uh provide explanation evidence
prediction exploration as well as
confirmation
and particularly with the augmentation
of simulations with machine learning
techniques in the creation of new
knowledge we have some really
interesting
new of what simulations
can do and what kinds of new discoveries
they might be able to enable
so the two case studies that i will be
looking at that
highlight the predictive power of
simulations so the first is a simulation
to study the formation and growth of
black holes and their host galaxies
and here what i want to illustrate is
the implications and impact of input
assumptions on the output
so these are simulations of structure
formation where
as i said in the scaffolding of dark
matter that aggregates only via gravity
normal matter falls in you form stars
and you form a black hole
that sinks to the center of uh galaxies
and grows
over time so the input assumption
till now till very recently except for
this one new simulation
that we have performed and analyzed
called romulus
is that the supermassive black holes
were pinned to the centers of the
galaxies where they form and grow
and so they were artificially pinned so
the consequence of part of the initial
conditions now the consequence of
relaxing this assumption
what is revealed in the simulation is an
entire new population of wandering
supermassive black holes
so i want to illustrate that with the
simulation and show you
um the impact of relaxing one assumption
so this is addressing the issue of how
the
input assumptions shape
the output of a simulation and in many
cases where restrictions of the input
actually circumscribe the kinds of new
discoveries and new knowledge that you
can get so in this case
we're actually generating new knowledge
uncovering an entirely new population of
black holes
and the second case study i'm going to
show you a brand new project in which we
have created a new platform which
co-locates
observational data and simulations that
enables new kinds of machine learning
techniques to be used to
disentangle this deeper causation and
correlation
um that i mentioned uh previously so
what you are seeing here is sort of the
basis
of most underlying cosmological
simulations and
i have separated out in two panels for
you the underlying dark matter
which is the web which is the cocoon in
which all the other activity that you
are going to see on the right hand side
which is the formation of stars the gas
that is falling in
the growth of the black hole and
material that's falling into the black
hole is generating these hot bubbles of
gas that you're seeing colored as red on
the right-hand panel
so in effect the simulation that i'm
going to show you actually does
all of this at the same time i have
separated out these two views
to show you roughly the sort of the
relationship
between these various components of the
universe
and as i mentioned the driving kind of
question for all of us in cosmology
is the causation sort of this connection
between the black hole
the host galaxy that it's sitting in and
the larger dark matter halo
the parent halo that hosts all the
activity
so let's move to looking at this
particular simulation
and i'm focusing now on one little
portion where we are forming a spiral
galaxy this is
a part of the same romulus simulation
that i just showed you
and this is the impact of relaxing the
assumption
of pinning down black holes artificially
to the center of their galaxies holding
them down
if you remove that anchor and you can
see these little white
dots um around the spiral galaxy these
are the wandering black holes
that have been brought in as the galaxy
is
assembling during mergers that we saw
visually previously
and you know on the sides i show you
these thumbnails of these recovered
populations
of wandering black holes so this is an
undetected
as yet undetected population of black
holes
that is predicted and now these
simulations have predicted the existence
of this population
and have allowed us to understand the
properties of this population the
demographics and the properties
and the origin and so now we can devise
strategies which we have done in a set
of papers to go look for them so this is
a remarkably different
role that simulations have started to
play and you know and it's
come out of relaxing one limitation of
the simulations
so here i'm sort of going back to
showing you
the integrated elements again
this uh movie of the romulus simulation
where you are simultaneously seeing the
dark matter is not visualized here and
what you are seeing
is the baryonic or ordinary matter
ordinary atoms
and you see gas flows and you see stars
forming and galaxies forming at the
intersections of these nodes of these
filaments
and you're seeing these gas bubbles that
are blown
so the activity the the flows the
activity
in terms of uh star formation
um and feedback from energy
feedback from the material that's
falling into the black hole that is
heating up the gas
is all simultaneously seen so you we are
now able to
visualize this underlying black hole
host galaxy
parent halo connection but what we
really want to do is to
study it more deeply and the challenge
with that
has to do with the fact that we have a
lot of empirical data
so here are uh a few
correlations that are seen in nearby
galaxies that all
contain dormant supermassive black holes
so these are not black holes that are
blowing the bubbles like the ones we saw
in the simulation
but these are black holes that are
sitting they have grown to the largest
possible size they can
and they've reached a maximum size they
are sitting and they're not
actively growing anymore so what we see
and that's
that is the case with all the black
holes seen in nearby galaxies
and what we find is there is there are
very interesting
strong correlations between the
properties of the black hole that is the
mass of the black hole
and the mass of the host galaxy the
luminosity of the stars in the inner
region of that host galaxy
and the velocity dispersion of stars in
that host galaxy
so the question is these are important
correlations
between properties of the black hole and
properties of the stars that are hosting
the black hole
in the galaxy that's hosting the black
hole uh this is the central black hole
now we're not talking about wanderers
i've moved on to the second case study
and so the question that we've all been
grappling with for decades
is do these correlations actually
point to some deeper physical causation
is this a causation that is set up does
do these correlations reflect some
causation that is set up in the very
early universe
and the growth the simultaneous growth
in
tandem do they reflect a growth in
tandem of the stellar component and the
black hole
that kind of makes sense because they
both grow from gas however we don't know
if this is a property of the initial
conditions of how black holes form which
we don't quite understand yet
we have some ideas we have some theories
that stand to be tested and validated
still with more data
but this question is really an open one
and it's the most important one in
understanding the growth over cosmic
time
of galaxies and their black holes
in the framework of these dark matter
halos that
both entities actually sit in
so the question as i said you know how
the first black holes form we don't know
how they actually grow we have some
clues and how they couple those bubbles
that we saw
is something that we do understand but
what is interesting is that although we
have data
that now shows us reveals to us
populations of quasars these growing
black holes out into very early epochs
in the universe
that data is highly incomplete we only
detect the brightest objects at earliest
epochs because
um because of the distance of how far
they are from us
and so we have an incomplete sampling so
the quantity that we would
really like to derive from observational
data that would
inform our theoretical understanding
models
and that we would like to recover from
simulations simultaneously
ab initio are two quantities the black
hole mass function which is the derived
distribution of black hole masses as a
function of cosmic epoch
and the luminosity function of quasars
as a function of cosmic epoch so these
are two constraints for our models and
our simulations need to
reproduce these constraints so in order
to do that
to deal with the fact that simulations
have limited volumes even with the
advances in computing
we cannot yet simulate a volume of the
universe that
corresponds to the size of the observed
universe
that we are actually probing with our
telescopes at the moment
so there's a real mismatch so in the
data we have incomplete data because we
preferentially see only the brightest
quasars
and with the simulations we don't have
an adequate volume to reproduce
and mimic the volume of the
observational survey in which we are
detecting these quasars
so in order to bring them both
into synergy we just recently i've
started a long-term project
a very exciting project that i'm leading
at yale
which is called quasar net and it's a
new research platform
that leverages machine learning
techniques for the data-driven discovery
of black hole populations are either to
undetected black hole populations
and so what we've done is we have
co-located
observational data and dark matter
halo data from simulations and the idea
is that we want to perform association
studies we want to
associate observed quasars
with locations in these simulations
and of course we have to use machine
learning to enhance the volume
of these simulations to match the
corresponding
survey sizes in which these quasars are
found
and then we can make a whole host of
assumptions about how to associate
quasars with particular locations and
then we can use machine learning to
derive
the properties of as yet undetected why
is this important this is important we
because we expect a real
deluge and observational data in the
coming decades
and so let me briefly tell you uh give
you some features
of the power of simulations and in
particular the way they are leveraged in
quasar net
and it has to do of course with
visualization
and the discovery of new correlations so
these are just a few
outputs from quasar net so all of our
data and codes is available online
uh on the google public kaggle platform
so these are just some um visualizations
from quasar net
of the data so we've compiled
observational data of high red shift
quasars all known high region of quasars
detected optically
are part of quasar net we've homogenized
it i was very painstaking
work and what we can then do
with this collated data is we can look
for all kinds of correlations and that's
what is shown in the central panel
and we are able to construct this black
hole mass function that i mentioned
is one of the key inputs that informs
our models and the simulations and so
the other thing that we can do i talked
about the association and what is shown
here
is what is called a halo merger tree
which is tracking the assembly history
of dark matter shown in the black dots
over time
and the galaxies that form in these
halos and the black holes so what is
shown in red
is the most massive dark matter halo at
any given time
and as a function of epoch so you see
the build up of this dark matter halo
that you see at the end is the most
massive one
and this most massive one most likely
hosts the brightest quasar
so we can play these associations we can
locate the brightest quasar in the most
massive halo and then we can tr
trace back the assembly history of that
black hole in tandem
with the assembly history of the parent
dark matter halo and the host galaxy so
these kinds of new studies are going to
become possible now
and as i mentioned the current key
limitation
for doing this kind of correspondence
direct correspondence between
observational survey volumes and
simulation volumes
is sort of the mismatch at the moment
but with machine learning we can start
with a small simulation
box with very high resolution and we can
use machine learning to derive the
characteristic
properties learn and derive the
characteristic
underlying properties of all the dark
matter halos and galaxies in that
simulation
which will then allow us to draw from
that distribution to enhance the volume
to create a much
larger volume simulation one that is
matched to the observational data better
and then we can do these association
studies
to ferret out the causation for some of
the correlations that we actually see
so this is sort of new work that we're
doing that i'm very very excited about
and it really illustrates the power that
cosmological simulations have
and in in terms of generating
discoveries they were never believed to
be generative
but i think we are now seeing that in
combination with machine learning
in particular it is starkly seen that
they could be driving discoveries in the
next couple of decades
so i want to close with thanking my
collaborators and give a shout out in
particular
to sunny tang who is a graduate student
at uiuc who did a lot of the heavy
lifting for quasar net
and my former phd student angelo ricardi
who
has done a lot of the work on the black
hole growth models
michael treville a postdoc at yale who
was part of the team that developed the
romulus simulations that i showed you
that we are using for our analysis
and my many other collaborators i also
want to thank google x
for their support with computational
resources and
collaborators on this project and a
whole host
of computational resources
across national facilities locally at
yale
and so on thank you very much for your
attention
greetings my name is brandon obunu and
i'm here to offer some thoughts on the
concept of
unfolding models in the context of
cutting-edge questions
in biology
when we think about this question right
about unfolding
right one of the curiosities that i
think about is what does that actually
mean
in the context of something like biology
and what i've interpreted as is
something about kind of like
disentangle right unfolding can mean
many things it can mean kind of just
exposing revealing but i think biology
in particular
offers this means of thinking about
unfolding in a particular way
now what do i mean by disentangling and
what in the context of biology
are we attempting to disentangle with
models
right maybe most famously mostly
most notably is the concept of protein
folding right and that one is very
literal and i think that one has kind of
gotten a lot of press recently
in particular in the computational realm
for the tools that we're using to solve
this protein
folding problem right and the idea here
is that biological information
is encoded in a certain manner but
really operates in a three-dimensional
means
and that kind of is difficult challenge
to understand how you get
three-dimensional structure
from kind of unidimensional information
but i would offer that threat the
analogy of folding and disentangling
goes much further
we can go back to darwin one of the most
famous passages in all of biology
darwin talked about how it is
interesting to contemplate a tangled
bank
right and what darwin was talking about
in this context
is the notion of life interconnected
that the biosphere
and that the laws of natural selection
are operating
on all of these different species in all
of these different ways
but this tangled bank analogy is
profound
right and i think importantly in this
famous passage
right he talks about how this tangled
bank
uh is the it is the substrate through
which
these laws have been acting around us
these laws of nature and of course
evolution by natural selection right
and so really a lot of modern biology
and really biology since darwin and
even before darwin has been about kind
of taking
this web taking this tangled bank and
disentangling it
and we can kind of move that towards
very modern problems right
right so for example you think about
modern ethical issues about genetic
modification
ethical issues about genetic determinism
about gene editing right
or just kind of even con you know modern
kind of ai
and machine learning and form problems
writ large and a lot of it is about kind
of
this mishmash between the data that
we're collecting
the things that we want to understand
and the implications they have for
society
now of course these are outside the
scope of any presentation
but these are all kind of cutting edge
modern problems
where this tangled bank that darwin
introduced us
manifests right but much
more practically in the context of
biological problems
right disentangling involves better
understanding the flow of
information through something we call
the
central dogma right the central dogma
is itself a type of model and what it
describes is the flow of
information from dna to rna and protein
and all of these
other variations but though the central
dogma is a very
simplistic description of the way
biological information works
right as you'll see on that figure on
the right right the fact of the matter
is
it is a very very complicated act
to go from biologic information genotype
to phenotype or fitness as evolutionary
biologists would describe it
it is in our effort to disentangle this
tangled bank the one that darwin
described originally
and has manifested in a lot of modern
problems that we really need
models models kind of allow us to make
sense of these types of things
we'll describe civil kind of conceptions
of what models are
we'll start with one that was introduced
in philosopher daniel dennett's
darwin's dangerous idea and daniel
dennett discussed was the notion of
being able to understand
kind of the way a calculator works when
you ask the question of how a calculator
works what are you asking he was talking
about the notion of
why is it that when you put a certain
computations in
you get a certain answer and what he
said was that understanding
a calculator at the level of every
individual
electron and the way that works at an at
a
great level of detail does not really
help you
think about the way the actual
calculations are done
right and the way he kind of introduced
this and brought at home was by
describing
a calculator that computes wrong answers
this hypothetical
thought experiment of a calculator that
computed wrong answers
in that situation if your job was to
understand why a calculator was kind of
producing wrong answers understanding
these electrons would not help you there
and so it's important to think about
what is the thing that we're curious
about
like what are we trying to model right
are we trying to model the way electrons
are flowing through a set of circuits or
what have you or the quantum behavior of
electrons in this
system called the calculator or are we
trying to get to the computational logic
of why it is
this instrument is producing this answer
and so the key point here is that it's
critical that the anatomy of the model
and the understanding embedded within it
reflects the level of the question
right understanding everything at a
really really really
infinitely reductionist level does not
help us
answer all of the questions and this is
where kind of a little bit of
understanding comes in
and domain expertise comes in
the other kind of conceptions of models
right can be captured by these famous
quotes
this one by george p box that all models
are wrong but some are useful and this
other one by samuel carlin that the
purpose of miles is not to fit the data
but to sharpen the questions
now each of these kind of captured right
various aspects of the way we think
about the purpose of models and what
they're good for
this first quote by george box kind of
actually captures some of the flavor of
daniel bennett
and the notion there is that right well
you know it
we don't need to understand everything
about the system we just need to
understand something about it that it
kind of addresses a question that we're
interested in
and somewhat relatedly samuel carlin is
basically saying that well
it doesn't have to reflect reality
but it has to kind of give us something
that allows us to be able to create
better questions that we can now take
forward right and you know those are
kind of useful quotes in some regard
right but there are other conceptions
that we can think of that are much more
detailed right
how about like the model as a scientific
instrument
right you can think about this be it a
turntable or a woodwind instrument or
whatever
instrument you want to think about all
these instruments can play songs they
can cover a remix songs and they can be
used to kind of play
new music and offer the world new music
right
similarly we can think about a
scientific instrument
it can recapitulate or explain past
phenomena
right it can understand predict yet
unseen phenomena
or it can generate new questions and
hypotheses so in the context of an
epidemic for example a lot of
mathematical models try to understand
the way an epidemic happened and that's
important right for us to kind of
potentially being able to predict future
ones to understanding how is it that 19
influenza happened the way that it did
of course the understanding and
predicting of yet unseen phenomena
is really really important but because
this kind of allows us to potentially
predict
things that haven't happened based on
information that we have now this one is
obviously contentious in the modern
times in the context of the pandemic
because a lot of models
haven't been exact and accurate but
they've been important nonetheless
and lastly sometimes models are just
theoretical and they allow us to kind of
highlight what our ignorance is all of
these are important uses of
models right they're different
modeling instruments we talked about
kind of where whether it's turntables or
woodword instruments you could use that
analogy
we can use mathematics and computer
science and they're different kind of
ways that we can kind of capture
different aspects of reality
mathematics of course is very kind of
transparent it puts all the assumptions
out there
and there's still discovery in the
process of mathematical modeling
but you see what the pieces are very
clearly where right whereas with
computer science right there's a lot of
what we call black boxes
of course the strength of computer
science approaches like agent-based
modeling for example
is they allow you infinite control
almost infinite control over what the
agents are
so in the context of an epidemic you're
not assuming that all
individuals in a population are the same
these are assumptions you often make in
mathematical models
in computational models you're able to
kind of wire individual behaviors and
therefore
ask a different set of questions and we
can kind of see this playing
out right in the context of a
mathematical model this is both
these are both of cholera outbreaks
all right and one of them is kind of a
mathematical kind of simulation that
looks at
the way that different intervention
strategies influence the dynamics of
cholera
in the context of computer science you
can kind of very you can capture
a lot of the capriciousness of epidemics
with regards to how individuals
operate and act over space place
right but the one i want to focus on
finally and where i put a lot of my
recent effort is this notion of the
model as an analogy
right you can think about from punnett
square
to the central dogma in biology these
things are all
stand-ins for something now they're
often quantitative but not necessarily
right the central dogma dna to rna and
protein doesn't have any numbers in it
but it is a model or an incomplete one
the one that we continue to prove on
for the way information works right and
one very very famous
analogy we'll use comes from john
maynard smith this one's been
transformative for a lot of people
in 1970 john mader smith published this
paper
natural selection in the concept of a
protein space
and in this manuscript john maynard
smith offered an analogy
for adaptive evolution in proteins that
ended up becoming profoundly influential
across a lot of different disciplines
the 2018 nobel laureate
dr francis arnold discussed the
importance of this paper
in the trajectory of her own work during
her nobel lecture
now what did john maynard smith do in
this manuscript
he basically compared evolution to a
popular word game called
word ladder right right that many of us
have played
and the idea here is the goal here is to
go from one word to another changing one
letter at a time
and in this context right you could ask
the question which of these is a winning
path
that wouldn't work the word the path
from word to war
to gore to gone to gene would be the
winning path
because all of the words are meaningful
and the idea here is that an evolution
can move through space
in an incremental fashion it does not
need to solve complicated
problems all at once it can move through
it kind of in an incremental manner
even more so john maynard's missing
analogy is important because it
identifies that
solutions to adaptive problems are often
located
in networks for evolution to work and be
a kind of
an effective algorithm for solving
problems it need not
search the entire expanse of possibility
but it needs to kind of search
local spaces in order to find solutions
often
this is a profound analogy right it's a
rich abstraction
right um and it kind of contains many
other ideas within it
this idea of a fitness landscape
adaptive trajectories
all of these kind of complicated
problems live within protein space
right because you can kind of take this
metaphorical protein that john maynard
smith identified
and we can think about like we can ask
some questions what if we're thinking
about something different
what if we're thinking about an actual
protein defined by four amino acids
described by those kind of single letter
substitutions and we were asking
something about okay well
how does an enzyme that is the target of
drugs
evolve drug resistance we can ask the
same types of
questions that john maynard smith asked
in 1970
so from this gamified analogy we can
recapitulate a lot of the importance
of kind of uh of biology and important
questions in evolutionary biology
right in using this abstraction right
we can get to fundamental laws and one
that i think is
as cutting edge and important as any law
in science one that we don't have yet
a fundamental law of evolvability
when john maynard smith was describing
moving from word
to gene he was describing the ability of
evolution to be able to find
solutions to complicated problems i
would argue that models like this one
can frame the next generation of
important ideas
in evolutionary biology the notion that
not all things are evolvable
and maybe we can be able to predict the
direction that evolution will move
i would argue that this is right up
there with the unification of the laws
of physics
so in closing we can talk about what
does it mean to unfold
models unfolding models articulates
several important points the fact that
we can use them to disentangle
right complicated problems defined by
multiple actors and
operators like epidemics and we can use
very very simple models like the kind of
word
ladder analogy for protein evolution to
consider
basic questions about evolutionary
possibility
this would influence agriculture this
could influence what we think about
productive evolution in the context of
epidemics
genetic modification biomedicine
all these problems defined by the
uncertainty
in being able to predict evolution are
the type of questions where models can
help us
move forward at this time i wanted to
express
my gratitude to all the individuals
involved
with organizing and creating this
important space
that is unfolding intelligence this is a
critical time to be asking this
these questions and i've greatly enjoyed
this opportunity
thank you
i would like to thank both stefan
helmheich and tana solomon
at cast mit for letting me present
resolution studies
in this special occasion my name is rosa
minkman and i'm a
dutch artistic researcher
last year i released a little book
titled beyond resolution
and in this little book i probed the
field of resolution studies
through the computational image both
practically
and theoretically in this presentation i
would like to highlight
three main perspectives from this
research
first an ecology of compression
complexities
second the rheology of data and finally
the impossible image and its
latent image space but i'll start with a
short introduction into what actually is
resolution studies
a technological resolution is the result
of a consolidation
or the bridging of the material
qualities
of certain objects they involve for
instance
shutter speed versus aperture the type
of ccd
chip or other standards such as
interfaces protocols etc
in short the setting of a resolution
comprises of the designed affordances of
these objects
and as a result and i think this has
already been
well described by alex galloway in his
book the interface effect
they influence the final use of the
technology
the standardization of resolutions is a
process that generally
imposes and enforces efficiency on our
technologies
but it doesn't just involve the creation
of protocols and solutions
it also entails the obfuscation of
compromises
and by doing so resolutions black box
alternative possibilities
which are as a result in danger of
staying forever
unseen or even forgotten
for instance in terms of data zero and
ones
on and offs raw data or even jpeg
encoded data
formatting defines not just how it's
stored
shown or sent to in-between technologies
but also
what data is actually stored because
while some data is privileged or
preferenced
other forms of data are unsupported and
even cut away
so the cost of media resolutions are
that we have gradually become
unaware not just of the habitual choices
but also of the compromises they
represent
and as such the habituated violence they
inhibit
a dynamic which wendy chun also
elaborates on
in her book updating to remain the same
resolution studies should therefore not
just involve a theory about the setting
of standard affordances
but also and maybe more conspicuously so
a studies into the compromised and
possibly
other implementations of data
in this presentation i will over three
methods
to fragment the black boxed
computational image
which is a term i borrow from alan
warburton
as a means to think through some of
these normally unthought or
inconsiderate compromises and
[Music]
possibilities
an ecology of compression complexities
the choice of an image compression
depends on its foreseen mode and place
of usage
while the compression of an image that
is meant to be printed will probably
honor the digital image data to a t
making sure no compression aberrations
take place
an image sourced for digital
redistribution will
likely use an algorithm that will cut
away visually less relevant information
to enhance faster file transfer so in
short
every image compression renders the
image data following a particular bias
benefiting its intended usage while
possibly rendering
the file imperfect for other modes of
use
it is therefore important to realize
that bias doesn't just exist in the
final rendering of the image
bias also exists in what technology
doesn't show what is obscured
obfuscated deleted or not rendered
so for instance the lossy jpeg
compression which uses dct or a
macroblock compression
to quantize space cutting away useless
or
underpreferenced data leaving whole
blocks of quantized voids
the lossy jpeg compression has only ever
been
calibrated to lena a caucasian
color reference card a card that has
caused
a white shadow on the history of digital
images
but what if lena were black how would
this have changed the jpeg compression
how does have changed all its subsequent
algorithms including the whole mpeg
family
to paraphrase heater style we need to
pay attention to the back of the images
or the image data the spaces that are
not captured or processed
where data is missing or the resolving
technology hides something
or cuts it away from our view
this is why last year i went to the
headquarters of iso
to lay flowers and commemorated the
absent
unaccepted and depreciated standards
however
i am also deeply aware that it's not
just the international organization for
standardization
that is responsible for these standard
shadows or the embedding of bias
and the preclusion of other uses of our
media
we actually all are responsible the
developers
independent or not artists and users
so how do we move beyond or beside these
generally imposed flows of data how can
we
actually break away from our standard
resolutions
i think a starting point is to realize
that any resolution is more than just a
formal solution
resolutions involve determinations that
can actually be rewritten
they can be fragmented or broken up and
with
that understanding in mind i created a
vernacular file formats
in a vernacular file formats also adopt
a guide to databand compression design
i explored the syntaxes of different
digital compression algorithms
by compressing one image via different
compression languages
and then subsequently implementing a
same or similar
error into each file to let the
otherwise invisible compression language
present itself onto the surface of this
original image
[Music]
but years after the release of the
vernacular these glitches actually
became
more and more common to popular culture
what once was simply deemed
glitch art or erroneous now seemed to
obtain a whole new secondary meaning
like a signifying skelemorphix these
glitches became indexical in their
own complexities for instance
while analog noise would be used to
indicate the presence of ghosts in any
hollywood movie
line artifacts usually warn us of the
threat of aliens
and i believe this is because in the end
humans always win over the aliens so the
rendering of communications
of these alternative life forms should
not be
so complex
blocky glitches generally signify time
travelling while any combination of
these artifacts
possibly mixed with vectors often
illustrate
the complexities of artificial
intelligence
the statics of glitched compressions has
thus become an informed material
vernacular
they are what susan shupley would
describe as material evidence or the
material witness
of their environment
in an ecology of compression
complexities i map
these different complexities of
compression artifacts
the map features the rims of pixels
lines
blocks wavelets and vectors but on a map
these complexities do not actually exist
separate from each other
they do overlap and this is because
while in our computational images these
complexities exist only in particular
stacks
and are therefore somewhat separate data
itself can actually
easily be transcoded from one complexity
to the next
so while the encoding or decoding of
data follows
certain protocological or imposed
complexities
data itself should actually be
considered as a fluid
i can actually listen to a rainbow
or take a look at the sound of rolling
laughter
in an ecology of compression
complexities i met the different
complexities
right next and on top of each other
because key to the study of resolutions
is the knowledge that data can be
fluid every string of data is
ambiguously promiscuous
and has the potential to be manipulated
into anything
even into a new complexity we should
therefore
actively practice or even train
ourselves to maintain
a rheology of data and i use this
terminology here as borrowed from the
realms of physics or
to be more precise from mechanics in
which the term is used to describe
the flow of matter primarily in a liquid
state but also
soft solids or solids that respond in a
plastic way
by the rheology of data i mean a study
of how data can be read and displayed in
completely different forms
depending on context software or
interface
but also with regards to our senses and
this is because our senses read and
process data in quite different ways
while our ears easily recognize patterns
over time
our eyes can specialize at the immediate
scanning of a plane for irregularities
or clusters
so different sensors can perceive and
learn from the same data set
in entirely different ways
they give us access to different forms
of pattern recognition
one is time-based and the other is
space-based
the reality of data advocates fluidity
in our data transactions
but also underlines the possible loss of
knowledge that may
appear when the formatting of data is
treated as a non-fluid
brittle or predetermined object
as standards stay uncontested one might
end up losing the potential for
new or other perspectives
a narrative that was part of this
deciphering
a work in vr that i made for dimota the
digital museum of digital art
and that was later also shown by
transfer gallery in new york
dct siphoning is a contemporary
translation of the
1884 roman written by
edwin abbott abbott titled flatland
but instead of a basic euclidean object
that is the protagonist in the 1884
version
dcd siphoning features an
anthropomorphized dct
and the dct algorithm is what lies at
the very basis of the jpeg compression
in dct siphoning dct senior
narrates the story of its very first
siphon
or a data transfer together with
dsd junior
their narrative illustrates their
interactions as they translate data
from one realm of image compression
complexity to the next
senior tells that when they siven away
from the blocks which is
the realm in which they normally
resonate to the planes of pixels and
lines
junior actually soon gets bored
as they sive and on to the realms that
are more complex than they are
themselves
junior actually gets excited and reaches
a limit to its stack
as they finally enter the realms of
factors
junior seems to get scared because of
eligibility issues
it refuses the chaos and leaves but
senior
remains in all
an angel of history calmly sinks to its
dcts
this is information
unlike data information spans over
multiple dimensions
it can move upwards not just northwards
it finally commits
to dct
i would like to follow this short and
quite abstract story
with a story from my own childhood
because i think
there is a direct connection
i recently found this page of my diary
back it reads
i finally know what i want to do when i
grow up
i want to discover new sounds in space
when the 10 year old me shared this
dream with one of my teachers
i was told that there are no sounds in
space and my dream was shattered
only later in life i learned that there
are actually
many ways to listen and that thinking
through sound in space
might actually mean to consider an
extended form of listening
which can be done through different
antennas or by extending the range of
messengers one listens to
maybe for instance cosmic rays different
types of particles
or waves that
maybe to a scientist space could
actually be full of sounds
during my collide at cern and barcelona
residency
i told a physicist about my
re-evaluation or expanded understanding
of perception
he responded to me with this story every
time
i watched the stars with my young
daughter i tried to tell her i tried to
explain
that what she is really looking at is
the neverending resonance of the big
bang
the light of the stars we see today is
also the momentary state of resonance
of the loudest sound the universe has
ever heard
my conclusion is that standard
resolutions can be useful determinations
they can work to make our everyday life
run smooth they make
things function but they're also
presumptions which puts them by default
at
risk to preclude alternatives to
perpetuate harmful clutched ways of
running
listening or understanding and finally
they can block experiments
in new ways or other ways of seeing
impossible images and the latent image
space
during my time at cern i interviewed
over 40 scientists
i asked them imagine you could obtain an
impossible image
of any object or phenomenon that you
think is important
with no limits on spatial temporal
energy
signal to noise or cost resolutions
what image would you create
the collection of impossible images i
have collected so far is fantastic
they already illustrate a diverse array
of limits on resolution or impossibility
but also on the technologies of what
imaging can be
itself a preliminary categorization of
impossible images
would entail images that are impossible
due to spatial or time or other types of
resolution
images that were deemed impossible in
the past but that have become
possible today images that were possible
in the past
but that are no longer possible images
depending on speculation
disbelief or imagination and images of
objects that can only be
inferred involving a substantial
signal-to-noise bounty
i organized a collection of impossible
images in a low poly rendition of what i
called
unquantifiable blob of impossible images
the blob or binary large object
is home to the collection of impossible
images that all together
illustrate the concept of impossible
image and its relationships
with affordance resolutions and
compromises
when you enter the 3d space in front of
the blob
the visitor is welcomed by the angel of
history she stands there pointing to the
blob
a map reminiscing the realms of
compression complexities
standing right beside her while behind
her a staircase to nowhere points
upwards
one enters the blob through a portal
imaging the shadow of dark matter
on the right an image of the inside of a
proton shows
three quarks the tiniest known building
blocks of the universe
they are smaller than a wavelength of
light
in front of us an image of the quantum
vacuum
at a slice of plank constant time ish
shattering
space
left of it a missing image
and beside it an image of a sunset
on the labrador coast from susan
shupley's film candeson lie
in which shupley describes the story of
a photographic image that denied to
abide
the rules of the optical regime
normally these images would have never
found their way to our eyes
but the hypothetical realms of the blob
offer pasture
to these impossible renders
they show that thinking through
impossibilities means thinking through
liminalities it means to consider and
possibly expand the limits
of understanding what is possible
the blob gives a shape to the latent
image space
the space of any and all images past and
future
which in reality has become a fragmented
space of stacked predetermined actions
and affordances
consolidated in resolutions
standing here different axes of
affordance
titled x y z and alpha cut the blob
they define what is possible to resolve
but also
what images are compromised or in other
words
will never be rendered
through my research into resolutions and
impossible image
i see a need to keep fragmenting the
stacks
of the computational image but i also
recognize a growing ecology of theories
around the liminal image space including
but not limited to
virilio's synthetic image pharaoh keys
operational images rubenstein's
fragmented photographic images
tagline's invisible images dances
discorrelated images
fluecer's techno images for burdens
computational images
and of course styles poor image
in a time of exploded and exponent
photography
a time that recognizes that photography
no longer needs to be representational
lens or light based these theories help
us to understand not only what the image
is built off
but also what an image is or what the
latent image space
can be
the latent image can be used as a tool
to expand our perception and in doing so
it can open new ways
to see
you